majorité requise pour l'adoption de la
motion de censure sur la majorité
absolue des membres composants cet
assemblée 287 pour l'adoption 278 la
majorité requise n'étant pas atteinte la
motion de censure n'est pas adoptée
[Musique]
en réalité rien ne vous obligeait 49-3
le courage le respect des institutions
le respect de vos engagements aurait dit
conduire au vote nous voulions voter
même les groupes de la majorité voulait
voter ce vote vous l'auriez très
probablement perdu mais c'est la règle
en démocratie
50 jours pour discuter d'un texte un
temps de parole limitée des petits
accords de couloir des ministres qui
défilent pour parler d'une réforme juste
et équilibrée de gauche et qui ne fera
pas de perdants d'autres qui accusent
les grévistes de provoquer une
catastrophe écologique agricole et
sanitaire un vote bloqué au Sénat un
bras d'honneur à l'Assemblée pour finir
par un 49-3 sous forme d'aveugle de
faiblesse quelle misère morale et
politique ni légitimité populaire ni
légitime parlementaire vous avez
précipité le pays dans une crise de
régime alors chiche monsieur Macron
allons à la dissolution et demain nous
reviendrons plus en nombreux et encore
pour donner un gros plus puissant voire
majoritaire à Marine Le Pen car plus que
jamais je suis convaincu que nous sommes
la véritable alternance convaincue
qu'après vous ce sera nous combien de
fois avons-nous été interpellé par des
Français qui nous écrivaient ou qui nous
interpellait directement en nous disant
j'ai honte de regarder ces débats j'ai
honte de ce que l'assemblée est devenu
honte de ce bruit et de ce vacarme
permanent j'ai honte du tapis rouge que
vous dressez à l'extrême droite parce
que si l'extrême droite peut conclure
son discours en disant en 2027 c'est
bientôt c'est parce que vous êtes là et
parce que vous n'êtes pas un rempart
vous êtes en marche pieds ceux qui
déguisent le 49-3 en un outil
antidémocratique on la mémoire courte
ils oublient que c'est justement
l'affaiblissement du Parlement et
l'incapacité à légiférer dans les
situations de crise qui a conduit
certains à remettre en cause la
démocratie parlementaire voir la
démocratie tout court dans les périodes
les périodes sombres de notre histoire
nos 49 3 n'est pas l'invention d'un
dictateur mais le choix profondément
démocrate qu'a fait le général de Gaulle
et qui a approuvé le peuple français
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]